you see this the way that the the
endorsements are breaking down
huge breaking news in the rap community
lil wayne endorsed donald trump at the
end of last week
following on the heels of lil pump's
endorsement following on the heels of
fitty sense endorsement but then he
fiddy sent i guess
unendorsed trump but i think it was
probably just to do some creepy stuff
with chelsea handler again i suspect
he's actually gonna vote for trump still
and kanye west of course endorsed trump
people talk about how is trump doing in
the black community i don't know how
trump's doing in the black community but
i do know he's making huge inroads in
the rap community
he's make it it's insane rappers are
voting for republicans now
this is a reordering of politics and
that's what we're talking about for
tomorrow night
tomorrow night is going to be this huge
election and
i don't have predictions over what is
going to happen i've got my money on
trump
i've i've bet a modest amount of money
on donald trump
i can't really come to grips with the
idea that biden is way up in the polls
and yet no one shows up to his rallies
at all 18 seriously like 18 people at
his rallies
and you get 20 000 people at trump's
rallies like
it doesn't make sense to me that hillary
would lose in 2016
when there were many more reasons to
doubt trump and be afraid of a trump
presidency but now that he's done a good
job
now he's lost support and joe biden who
can't pronounce the meaning of words
who picked maybe the worst running mate
in presidential history
and whose campaign has openly embraced
socialism now in that campaign ad
that that guy is doing better than
hillary did that that guy is beating
trump
it's hard for me to believe that however
we do know that we're up against a
big issue in this country the mainstream
media big tech
big tech just took down the the new
jersey women for trump facebook page
huge
private facebook group 23 000 members
that's a private group so it's
much tighter knit more intimate they
took it down three days before the
election
so trump just tweeted that he goes at
facebook put them back now and then they
did they didn't
go get your shine box too they did put
it back but there are a lot of
shenanigans going on and
and big tech and the entire liberal
establishment and probably the
bureaucracy as well
probably the bureaucracy people involved
in the election to varying degrees
are trying to prevent trump from winning
so we're up against a lot
tomorrow night could be over in five
minutes if for instance if trump loses
florida or something like that
or it could i could i could see joe
biden winning 40 states i wouldn't be
surprised
or i could see donald trump winning
every state plus greenland
and i wouldn't be surprised either i
just don't know i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you